[Music]
as the last notes of my violin fell upon
the crowd the audience burst into
applause I had just finished the best
violin performance in my life to date
and I was feeling awesome I ran off the
stage up to my mom expecting praise
compliments hugs instead I was greeted
with in unenthused high-five and a/c
Helen if you just apply yourself like
this to other aspects of your life think
about how awesome you could be but that
hurt because her opinion mattered a lot
to me and I'm not sharing this story
with you to ask for your pity or because
I enjoy it throwing my poor mom under
the bus but because I can't race a lot
of my inability to give or receive good
compliments to my strict traditional
Chinese heritage but you don't have to
come from the same upbringing to maybe
also struggle with giving or receiving
compliments and because I'm an ex
consultant I'm gonna have you guys take
a look at a chart take a look at this
chart and take a moment and think about
maybe where you fall on this chart I'm
willing to bet if I took a poll most of
you guys would say me somewhere in the
middle but I'm also willing to bet a lot
of us actually unknowingly fall into
this bottom left-hand corner somewhere
between not being so great at giving
compliments and not being so great at
receiving them and today I'm here to not
only get us up to that upper right-hand
corner
but to also drive home the importance of
being in that corner
starting with receiving comp giving
compliments think about the last time
you gave someone a compliment what did
you say how specific or genuine do you
think it was when was it I asked these
questions because a lot of us again
don't realize how few good compliments
we give and there's a lot of good
reasons for that
for example thanks to the illusion of
transparency we believe that other
people know how we think or know what we
feel and that's not true
other times we're just trying to avoid
being awkward so we don't say anything
at all
and even worse sometimes we're a little
self-absorbed and so we forget about the
people around us as we freely focus on
what we're trying to get done what we're
trying to do but stick with me here
because there's really good reasons as
to why we need to become better
complimentary starting with the fact
that giving a good compliment actually
drives achievement at a very fundamental
level researchers of Japan recently
discovered that giving someone a good
compliment is equivalent to giving them
straight cash and yes I'm a poor grad
student right now so I love money but
this actually like any reward leaves us
wanting more it drives us to want to
recreate our stellar performance giving
an awesome compliment is also better
than giving constructive criticism this
coming from a researcher at the
University of Hamburg where he noted
that giving a good compliment
exacerbates our optimism bias we have a
feeling and we believe that good things
will happen and bad things won't so when
we give a good compliment where we
receive a good compliment we then
believe that we can actually achieve and
do something that maybe we wouldn't have
otherwise
and finally giving a good compliment
lifts moods it builds trust and it leads
to stronger relationships and the simple
act of just recognizing those around you
builds the foundations of reciprocity
and positivity that leads to
long-lasting relationships with all that
being said in order to actually achieve
all of these benefits you actually have
to give a good compliment so what's a
good compliment it comes down to giving
great the content and having great
delivery when it comes down to content
we're thinking about being specific
what exactly did someone do to deserve
that compliment well more specific we
avoid comparing people to each other and
we also show that we were really paying
attention we also want to be achievement
focus we want to think about what they
achieved versus what someone is because
when we think about achievement and we
talk about achievement it's something
that someone can repeat and someone can
do better
it's what triggers that reward Center in
their brain and when it comes to
delivery what we want to talk about is
being genuine and the easiest way to do
that is to just recognize the impact
that someone had on you and finally we
want to be selective as much as you guys
might walk away from this talk saying
you get a compliment you get a
compliment you get a compliment we want
to avoid doing that because when you
give too many compliments that
complement and that sincerity gets
diluted okay so now that you guys are
all awesome at giving compliments walk
with me to the other side as we talk
about receiving compliments when was the
last time someone gave you a compliment
how did you react was it potentially
with a question mark like thanks was
maybe with it oh no no it wasn't me it
was the team it was the weather it was
luck these reactions are so common that
sociolinguists have categorized them
into two categories rejection and
deflection and there's a good reason why
we also tend to dodge dip duck dive and
dodge compliments like we're playing
dodge ball and it all starts from when
we were kids
we're told that good people in strong
leaders are humble so we don't want to
come off as stuck-up we also have a
tendency to run away from the spotlight
so when someone shines the bright light
of praise on us our first reaction is to
run away
and finally especially in this room we
all tend to be a little self-critical
some of us very self-critical
and when someone gives us a compliment
we view it with skepticism what did we
even do to deserve it and this last part
is really important because when we
dodge a good compliment
we're actually devaluing the perspective
the time the heart that someone put into
giving us that compliment and just as
much as giving good compliments builds
up relationships dodging good
compliments breaks those relationships
down additionally when we dodge
compliments we're also missing out on an
awesome opportunity to better ourselves
we did something to really deserve that
compliment figuring out what that is
will make us better and stronger faster
so when it comes to receiving
compliments there's really just two
pieces acknowledge just say thank you
you're going to want to say more but
just stop at thank you internalize
really think about what you did to
deserve that compliment and how you
could recreate that and how you could
apply it elsewhere in your life
now admittedly as I stand in front of
you giving you all this sage advice on
giving compliments and receiving them
I myself continue to really struggle
with becoming a better compliment giver
and receiver it's hard but just the
other day I was teaching my
seven-year-old nephew how to throw a
frisbee and memories of that violin
recital came flooding back to me and I
wondered what I would have wanted my mom
to say in that moment and I was reminded
that this was my opportunity to not
repeat history so I countered each of
his throws with this very specific
targeted compliment and I watched as his
confidence grew I saw it in his eyes and
to think that I could have that kind of
an impact on a young child was a stark
reminder that my work that our work in
becoming better compliment givers and
receivers is never done
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]